hey guys how's it going I was gonna say
oh my goodness guess what I got but if
you can't notice I'm wearing it already
on my face so it beats the purpose of
you guys guessing but I finally got my
Google glass today I went to be able to
pick it up and they did a little
training session to teach try to use it
and give you all the ins and the outs
like so weird because I'm looking at
things right now through my third eye so
we're here I do a lot about it with my
Google glass and I'm so excited
so again we are going to kind of fit it
on for your features specifically with
wow that's a really nice bit I'll show
you this later it's actually doing an
update right now so disregard if you can
actually see something happening inside
of my glass screen hi so now what this
actually comes with is a little charger
these little shades that you can just
clip on so if you want to put a clear
shield or be really fashionable and wear
some sunglasses also comes with this
little bag it's very protective it's got
a little magical protection you just
stick them in there protected so what
kind of stuff would you guys like
beaches you with oh something happened
in my eye
glass has been updated perfect I don't
know what kind of stuff I really want to
do I mean so far the videos that I've
made are not really that riveting I was
eating a sandwich
I was never one like eat a sandwich with
Google laughs oh something's happening
one of the cool things it kind of freaks
me out is when I received a phone call
because the sound actually goes in the
back of your ear and it sounds like the
sounds are inside of fierro brain I
promise you there's a difference between
hearing someone talk to you and here in
Google glass inside of your head fruits
me out coming call it's you
wait how do I answer go on tap on the
side
you're talking so weird yeah it's like
I'm hearing you inside my brain a little
bag - so I'd like you guys to give me a
little challenge of what I should do in
Google glass and a lot of people on
Instagram were saying that they probably
wouldn't want to talk to someone who the
Google glass and honestly that was my
initial thought I was like I will never
talk to anybody wearing this because I'm
freaked out you oh I'm sorry did you
want me to do did you want something
okay you're able to kind of see if
somebody's recording and you have to go
like this this is the processor record
you lift your head up turned on okay
glass record a video oh look at me I'm
recording a cut look a mess but I turned
my opposite you stuff stuff stuff so
there's one little flaw okay glass take
a picture no no I don't want to take a
picture let's do it has a default you
can only record ten-second videos so I
mean you're not gonna be sitting there
recording somebody the entire time and
you can see that it's doing something
also somebody's trying to take a picture
I mean they're gonna be going like this
okay glass take a picture like how
subtle is that not settle at all and
then to record a video like look people
are gonna say so I'm not that concerned
about it
I mean slightly concerned shut up oh no
it's low battery it just turned off
great looks like I need to charge it but
excited I think it's gonna be really fun
I just definitely hope that the battery
lasts a little longer I think he says
the battery life will last about five
hours and I've been using it pretty much
on and off all day definitely make sure
you guys follow me on Google+ because
I'm probably gonna be posting all of my
Google glass adventures on there because
it's actually the easiest way to do I
mean you seriously just slide click
share' it's magic it's really the only
way I can explain it now there's
different gestures that you can use so
you can scroll this is kind of
touchpad so this will take you forward
into the settings except my hair keeps
getting in the way and it'll take you
backwards and then to cancel an action
you go like that and to completely just
turn off glass
feel like that there's two little
buttons too so this is the power button
I'm not sure what this button is it says
glass on it so I'm really sure actually
that's glass my friends I'm gonna see
what it looks like if I put these
glasses on I mean you can't even tell
that I'm wearing Google glass right now
can you so futuristic
well that is all I've got for you guys
today let me know your thoughts on
Google glass what are your concerns what
are you excited about these still aren't
100% released to the public right now I
think the only people that have them are
the Google glass explorers or the people
that tweeted if I had glass to Project
Glass
so that's how I got mine and it's pretty
pretty sweet it's kind of crazy I don't
even know what to say about it it's just
the strangest thing really it's I wish
you guys could actually see you what I'm
seeing I will see you all soon I'm gonna
go out at the studio now and I will see
you later
my
[Music]